Speaker 1: Let's hear from some people in
the audience.
We now take calls via Discord.
It just works better.
It works better than the things we used to
do.
You can find the discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord.
Let's go first to Kevin from Grand Rapids,
presumably.
Is that Michigan, Kevin?
Kevin, from Grand Rapids, you were on the
air.
And last chance for Kevin from Grand Rapids,
Kevin, please.
Speaker 3: Hello.
You're on the air.
You can hear me
Speaker 1: now, I can.
Speaker 3: Oh, thank you.
Hey, David, great to have a call.
First time caller.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm calling.
I don't.
I kind of not starting off on a super topical
line because I know the elections happened
last night.
And, you know, that's kind of a lot to talk
about.
But I had a question kind of a general one.
Would you agree that it seems like people
on the right are a lot more organized as one
these days, in a sense that like they seem
to agree and like work towards goals at least
slightly or mostly better than people on the
Left do and what we could do to maybe come
together and start to have some of that presence
that people on the right seem to be getting
one up on us with.
Like, I don't know, I consider myself self
a democratic socialist, but I know that there's
a lot of people like people are a little more
liberal than I am that might like.
We might disagree on certain things.
I don't need to get into the specifics specifics
of it, but I just I kind of think that it
seems like the left is a little less cohesive
and together and a little bit more prone to
like nit picking things where I think you're
right,
Speaker 1: Kevin, I've got a few videos on
this, and indeed, I do think that there are
some on the left who sometimes let the perfect
become the enemy of the good.
It's definitely an important issue and one
I've talked about.
But Kevin, I'm going to let you go because
that smoke detector that you got to deal with
that, OK, my friends, so do with this.
Speaker 3: That happened last night.
I got to get a nine volt battery.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
Yep.
All right.
Thank you.
Kept very good.
We've got a lot happening there.
I'm going to let him get to it.
Let's go next to Isaiah from Arkansas.
Isaiah, you were on the air.
Hi, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: And well, I have a question, but
first, I'm a follow up with what Kevin said
in.
There's definitely an issue with.
Democrats just being terrible at campaigning
effectively, there was kind of my conclusion
from Virginia and New Jersey.
Yeah.
And in the state of Arkansas, where you know,
we have like five Democrats elected in the
entire state anywhere, there is just so much
incompetence and so much of anybody working.
And I don't want to take too long, but to
say it quickly.
I was in a I was in a I'm in college.
I was in a group that was.
Roy collecting like a young Democrats group.
And I said that based on how disorganized
the party is right now, we should be focusing
on and voting in the in the Republican primaries
to keep out the extremist because in Arkansas,
you can you have to take which primary vote
in.
Right.
And I got kicked out of that group for, as
they said, spreading Republican propaganda.
So I give her basic things like that of strategy,
either kicking out people.
And how do you expect to accomplish anything?
Sure.
Of course.
I think in total thing
Speaker 1: well, voting in Democrat, in Republican
primaries, when states allow you to vote in
either as a way to keep out the worst candidate
is a much discussed strategy that has been
talked about for a while.
I think it's certainly a very interesting
one.
I think you're absolutely right that part
of what went wrong in Virginia is that Republicans
are at a structural advantage.
It's much easier to motivate people to vote
based on anger and fear in Virginia.
A lot of it was about education and critical
race.
Theory and fear and anger are just better
motivators to get people to engage with the
system.
And that's something that the right uses significantly
in this country.
So I think your analysis is exactly right.
Speaker 3: Mm-Hmm.
And in Arkansas, I might be wrong about this,
but I believe you have to either vote in the
Republican or Democrat.
You can't vote in both in the primary.
I think that that's the
Speaker 1: case, and that's I believe that's
the case in every state.
You can't vote in both primaries.
Speaker 3: Yeah, we have.
The fact of the matter is, as it stands in
twenty twenty two, the election in March,
whoever wins the Republican primaries in the
office pretty much is going to win in November.
And we have, I think, a character.
I don't know if you're familiar with them,
but I think you'll be more familiar with them
in the future.
Have you heard of Jason or.
No.
He is a real United States senator we have
that's running for lieutenant governor.
And anyone listening just read the Wikipedia
article on him kind of speaks for itself,
but I don't want to take up too much of your
time.
But my question is for someone like me living
in Arkansas.
I think obviously I'm kind of moderate with
you, if you want to say what you think the
most effective way to actually change the
political demographics of the state.
Or do you think it's just better to just get
out altogether?
Speaker 1: That's it's your call as to whether
you want to get out or not.
It wouldn't be illegitimate to get out if
you decide that you just want to improve your
circumstances immediately, rather than work
to improve everybody's in your state.
But get in, find local races, find candidates
that are that are doing the right things as
far as you're concerned and get get involved
in those campaigns is the best advice I can
give.
All right, my friend, I'm going to move on
because I've got a lot of people waiting
just
to chat.